- I know you said you go to
Austin, do you miss Texas food?
I love Texas food.
- It's you know, it's funny,
when I make my plans with my friends
it's always around where we're gonna eat.
(chuckles)
- Absolutely. Why not?
Absolutely.
- How many times we could cram tacos
into the schedule, you know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That's.
- [Kelly] 'Cause it's Tex Mex
- Cause it's Tex Mex.
- Yes, it's different than here.
So when I moved here, I was
like, what is this Mexican?
It's quite authentic Mexican food.
- Why their mango in my salsa?
- I know I was like, why?
Why? And the strawberries,
is that new for guac?
Okay, cool.
- [Guest] And why is my why's
my iced tea, passion fruit?
Like what?
- [Kelly] Yeah, I just want a normal one.
- I just want a lemon. (chuckles)
- [Kelly] Yeah, it is, I love Tex Mex,
so that's my favorite thing.
And I, thought that maybe
you might mix, miss it.
So I, brought you, you something.
- [Guest] What?
- Okay, here we go. I'm a
polite host. I'm a polite host.
(Crowd Cheering)
You have a drink and some queso.
- [Guest] I don't know.
- Okay, No wait, wait.
- We're gonna have to wrap this up.
- Wait, hold on, sit
down for a minute, wait.
'Cause here's the thing I have been,
this is season three,
since season one, I have been searching
for like good queso in LA.
This queso it's from
Roadside Taco right here
in Studio City. Shout
out because it awesome.
- [Guest] Okay.
- I'm not even being paid by them.
I just really love this queso.
- It does look good.
- [Kelly] But I need you to like maybe
do you want take to taste?
- No, No I'm in.
- Okay. We have our own.
- I'm so in.
- We have our own.
- Is this mean.
- [Kelly] Covid friendly.
- [Guest] 'cause everybody's
leaning forward everywhere?
- I don't know, but my mouth
is watering,I'm so excited.
- I know, I'm a little happy
about it. Oh, you guys?
- I know.
- I'd like to apologize in advance
'cause this looked really good.
(crowd laughs)
- [Kelly] It's good.
It needs to be warmed up
a tiny bit, but whatever.
It's really good.
- [Guest] I mean.
- [Kelly] But I like it
when it's warmed up heavily,
it's like really runny.
That's what I love.
- [Guest] I don't, you know what,
if you can do better than
that, my head might blow off.
It is so good.
- I know. It's so hard to
find good queso here, but.
- Thank you, cheers.
- Cheers. Oh, I did it before.
That's like rude. Oh, I like your ring.
- Ladies and gentlemen Kelly Clarkson.
Thank you what a sweet thing to do.